yesterday's White House press briefing
managed well first of all it was managed
not by press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders but by her deputy the deputy
press secretary Raj Shah and it got off
to a very very fast start because after
the endless lies and the lies about
firings and hirings and the lies about
so much Associated Press reporter Zeke
Miller straight up said to Raj as soon
as he turned it over for questions after
a couple minute comment why should we
believe anything that you tell us at
this point which is really a pretty
obvious question at this point scene is
very controversial and aggressive but
it's just sort of an obvious question
let's watch and most of what I'm most
interested in is the just laughable
response from Raj Shah here Zeke on
Thursday White House officials wrote a
lot of this stage and they said the
present would sign behind the best
legislation on Friday morning he
threatened to veto it ultimately decided
ten days ago sarah said that a charter
master had to present confidence and
support would be leaving last Thursday
yeah it was best that he would be
leaving the White House in about
two-and-a-half weeks ago the president
expressed confidence in his attorneys
and then there's a bit of a shake-up
there last week so can you talk to speak
to the White House the credibility why
should we in this room and more
important of the American people trust
anything of this administration is
telling them well you know our job is a
press office and as an administration is
to give you the best information that we
have available to us most accurate
information in a timely fashion
sometimes the dynamics are fluid in any
given situation you mentioned some
personnel matters facts and
circumstances changed we continue to
give you guys the best information that
we can as quickly as possible so good
for Zeke Miller right this is a good
question this is the type of question
that should be asked but the next step
if you've got to press them right Raj
Shahs answer is bogus unless the White
House press team is genuinely kept in
the dark about what is going on which is
possible in the Trump administration
anything is possible but it's sort of
hard to believe to say that they give
the most accurate information they have
at the time is obviously not believable
the White House press office hasn't been
in this level of disarray and disrepair
I would argue ever and it goes back to
the first day of this administration and
Sean Spicer who has done more to
embarrass and discredit the office of
the press secretary than any previous
press secretary and it started with his
day one pronouncement I call it the
belligerent pronouncement the coerced
pronouncement we now know by Donald
Trump that Donald Trump had the biggest
inauguration in the history of the
United States period end of story
Spicer started his tenure as White House
press secretary lying about the weather
on inauguration day something that
hundreds of thousands of people
personally experienced and millions more
watched on television and I also want to
point out that not just the lying but
the admitting to lying isn't that rare
in the administration we know that they
lie Donald Trump recently admitted as I
covered that he lied to foreign leaders
including specifically Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau we covered it
when it happened Trump just making up
assertions out of thin air about trade
with Canada just made it up
hope Hicks Trump's former I guess like
her 6th or 7th who knows White House
communications director she testified a
few weeks ago that sometimes she would
lie to the press for president Donald
Trump
Kellyanne Conway concocting the
bowling-green massacre to justify who
knows what depraved policy of Donald
Trump's that he was pushing at the time
some kind of wall or ban or travel ban
or whatever it was this is what they do
right so the answer to Zeke Miller's
question here is there is no reason why
anybody should trust any of these people
they should not be trusted and even
Trump came up once with the bogus live
just a demonstrable factual lie that he
had the biggest electoral victory in
history he was straight-up called out by
a reporter in person and just listen
Trump expressed no remorse he said I
well that's what somebody told me
I guess it was the biggest electoral
college win since Ronald Reagan
Ronald Reagan the 304 306 electoral
votes in fact President Obama got 365
well I'm talking about Republican
President Obama 331 George HW Bush 420
said oops when he won as president so
why should Americans trust well no I was
told I was given that information I
don't I was just given we had a very
very big margin I guess I questioned why
should Americans trust you when you've
accused the information they receive of
being fake when you're providing
information well I don't know I was
given that information actually I've
seen that information around yeah I was
thinking that a lot of people aren't
familiar with that one but it's it's bad
there is only one way in which what Raj
said is true Shaw said that the press
office provides the most accurate
information at the time it's possible
they have no clue what's going on right
they the press office may genuinely have
no reason to think that HR McMaster and
Rex Tillerson are about to be fired even
almost as they are being fired because
they're not being told that it's going
on and that's the one other
interpretation of this and I don't know
whether that's true that would signal a
whole host of other problems going on
within the White House my baby maybe
it's something that we will someday
learn about but hey I wish there were
more follow-up but good for Zeke Miller
for asking the question we can only hope
there's more of this coming from the
press corps I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
a quick break back after this today's
program is sponsored in part by
blinkin we all lead busy lives sometimes
it can sort of become a struggle to do
all the reading that we want to do I
know this is certainly true for me
there are probably a bunch of books that
you've been hoping to sit down with and
read but you've not yet been able to
find the time what if I told you that
you could read a full-size book in 15
minutes or even more quickly
that's basically what blink as'll aoz
you to do blankest is a mobile app that
takes thousands of the most popular and
critically acclaimed non-fiction books
and summarizes them into their most
important points and they present it to
you in the form of text or audio so that
you can either read it or listen to it
in
fifteen minutes you get all the same
information and insight from the book in
a fraction of the time you can search by
author or topic new books are being
added all the time it's an almost
endless diverse collection to choose
from politics science health and fitness
psychology parenting business you're not
going to run out I think is the point
I'm trying to make of fascinating
informative nonfiction reading and
listening material and blink astiz free
to try and membership after that is only
a few bucks a month and you can get a
20% discount off of that if you go to
blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube we've put a link in
the description underneath the video
that is blink accom /pa que ma n